can europe speak with one voice in the
escalating crisis in ukraine as russian
tanks remain stationed on the streets of
crimea mep's charles tanik from the
european conservative and reformist
groups and giver hofstadt from the
liberals and democrats give us their
opinions what's the future for crimea
what we absolutely need is a bold
uh attitude and bolt reaction by the
european union and we lack for the
moment that courageous
reaction of the european union
because let's be very clear about it if
we don't
have the courage to announce sanctions
including economic sanctions towards
russia yeah then it's clear that russia
shall simply incorporate
the crimea inside inside russia ukraine
gets closer to europe russia loses and
so he on a pack of lies basically he has
justified a military invasion of a
peaceful sovereign country it's a very
dangerous situation
there's a potential for a real bloody
war
and clearly putin is in no mood for
diplomacy not from the beginning he
wasn't he has a plan in his head which
is to occupy
first crimea and ideally half of ukraine
can russia justify its actions by
arguing the cost of a precedent it was a
a different story because there you got
the population would want to create a
new state an independent state and
on crimea the question is not that the
question is shall they uh continue uh to
be part of ukraine or shall there be
a part in the future of the russian
state of the russian federation what is
a totally different story in any way i'm
not against the fact that the local
population can express himself can
choose can make a decision about it but
it has to be under what i call normal
international democratic standards the
russians are contradicting themselves
they only allow self-determination when
it suits them none in chechnya have they
ever allowed self-determination chechnya
90-something percent chechens no this is
a case where they are using this as a
pretext which has no foundations and
international law and they are
signatories and guarantors of the
borders of ukraine including crimea and
don't forget in 1991 there was a
referendum in the whole of ukraine and
even in crimea there was a majority to
say we want to be independent from
russia and there were more russians
living there then than there are now
what sanctions should the eu take
two things have to be done first of all
announce a number of economic sanctions
for example uh not longer allowing that
dirty money
coming from russia
is invested in the city of london or in
german industry or in the real estate in
france or or in italy that's the first
thing to do uh including also visa ban
freezing of assets and so on and the
second thing to do is to develop now the
fastest as possible a common uh
energy policy let's face it russia
relies entirely on selling its gas to
european markets the pipelines flow in
that direction they rely on 100 billion
dollars a year if that was stopped or
reduced it'd be crippling on their
economy russians have chosen a very bad
timing in this respect the winter months
are behind us the americans very soon
will be exporting shale gas if they wish
to there is spare capacity from norway
from qatar from algeria the pipelines
can be reversed through slovakia to
western ukraine there's a possibility
that if we want to have really severe
economic sanctions of course europe
would pay a price it will be difficult
but it can be done